So this isn't good enough, but we can carry that solution through
and add random nonces to each of these layers, so that's what we're going to do.
The inner message will be the vote concatenated with a random nonce
encrypted with C's public key.
The next layer will be that message concatenated with a new nonce
and encrypted with B's public key.
And the outer layer will be encrypted with A's public key will be this message
concatenated with the third nonce.
So this is the message the voter sends with that voter's vote.
Party A will decrypt the outer layer, randomly permute, and send the result to B
and will decrypt B's layer, randomly permute, and send the result to C
and will decrypt the final vote.
And the first step to validating votes instead of just publishing the v values,
we're going to require that C also publish the r0 values.
So the final tally will be a list of votes and their associated nonces.
This means the voter can check that the nonce that the voter used is in that list.
So if we use this protocol, which of the three parties--
Apple, Blue, or Crazy - would you rather be?